Hello 欢迎大家来到影视机3线上穆克克的内容是讲解压扣的实际理念以及开发实践
主角也就是我 崔锦铭是蚂蚁集团安全算法增加
在这次分享中我们主要会从三个方向去介绍一下压扣和如何在天下开发
那废话不多说 第一部分我们会简单介绍一下
什么是压扣 压扣的实际理念是什么样子的
然后因为压扣是一个安全的密码库 所以在第二部分
我们会介绍一下压扣的安全性
而在第三部分我们会具体从一些case上看下
如果我们在压扣上去进行新的密码算法协议的开发是什么样子的
首先是第一部分 压扣的简单介绍
在整个银语1.0中我们可以看到从上到下分了很多层
压扣实际上是属于我们的计算层 向上去支撑我们的一些隐私保护银语
以及密探引擎上面的一些密码相关的一些实现
这里整个银语的架构我就不再举准述了 大家感兴趣的话
也可以去看一下我们的其他的穆克的视频 将接
在整个银语框架中的压扣是向上层提供了隐私计算密码算字
就比如说在密探引擎spo里面我们会提供一些ot或者一些其他的as加密的一些算字
当然除了这些隐私计算的密码算字也会提供一些基础加密
签名hash的工具供用上层的一些方向去使用
就常见的比如说mrsa的加密引擎签名
语题我们常用的sash1,sash2,sash3之类的一些hash的工具
除了这些之外 压扣实际上还提供了一个靠的随机源
允许我们是可以自己实现一个底层硬件的一个随机商人的接口
在整个运运开个框架由于安全性是至关重要的
所以而安全性主要来自于密码协议的实现者管
所以压扣需要有一个靠的安全保障
也需要向上层提供高性能的算字
因为上层的一些ai或者bi任务是非常吃性能的
然后第三点是我们希望压扣很容易使用
一边与我们的密码协议开发人员在压扣这一层可以直接去进行一些新的密码协议算法协议的开发
这里就会涉及到一个问题
当前实际上在业界或者说在开源上有很多密码库
我们为什么一与需要一个自己的新的密码库呢
我们首先先把这个问题放在一边
我们先看一下整个密码库在我们整个计算机软件的营运过程中是怎么样子的
首先我们有一个上层应用
上层应用就包括这里举的例子当然是隐私计算的
就比如说隐私计算的上层应用我们会有联合建模的许球
我们会有ps3的许球
我们会有pr2的许球
我们也会有cql的许球
那么这里你们统一看一个密码库
其实就是做一个密码理论和上层应用之间的一些调量
我们有非常多的密码理论
就比如说非常多的数学相关的密码理论和一些理论模型
那么实在实际上我们是想要把他们具体的去实现出来
提供一个安全的模块去滚上层的应用适用
那么密码库就是在这里起到这个作用的
实际上在现在业界的话
我们会有学术界密码库和工业界密码库的区别
在学术界密码库里边就比如说我们会碰到一些常见的
这大多都是高校在写一些文文的时候
他们去捧款是自己写的一些工具
或者说他们自己做的一些实现
那就比如说EMP和Libo提议
他们也有非常好的口碑
但是在这里学生码库是天然的是有一些劣势的
就比如说他们的他们他们底层的写意实现
可能是非常随意的
他们并不会严格的去遵守我们现在工业界的一些标准
实现就比如说我们国民的一些标准
或者released的一些标准
他们并不会去去特定的去往这边去靠
因为他们大多只是为了发布论文
去demo一下自己的协议的可行性
并不需要把安全性做得非常严谨
那么第二个部分是他们是针对学术场有优化的
就比如说我正常一个PSI
可能我会假设在这个场面里面
我实际上是不开通信量是多少的
那在这种情况下
他们就会去极大地针对无限待宽的这种场面去进行优化
而在现实中我们是很少碰到这种场面的
所以他的性能也会是一个问题
他可能并不能与工业界的一些马过去相比
第三个是他的应用性
他们一般会缺少长期为户
其实我们之前常见的一个ABY是一个非常典型的例子
ABY基本上在他们论文发出来了以后
可能是一七八年之后
可能就不太这么维护了
我们就会很少看到上面有一些供信
而这一方面可能是因为当时他们的作者
已经离校去公司或者去其他其他机构
这是学术码库的几个劣势
其实除了这些之外
我们还有工业精密码库
工业精密码库非常著名的就是我们的OPEN ASASA
那工业精密码库一般用什么劣势呢
它其实到目前为止我们可以看到
其实大多数计算机里边OPEN ASASA版本还都是1.1
实际上OPEN ASASA已经出到3点多了
其实它加入了非常多的新的特性
但是大家的更新迭代速度其实是非常慢的
即使OPEN ASASA到了现在3点新的部分
那其实就传统我们隐私计算用的一些东西
OPEN ASASA可能它并没有去把这些去夹进去
它的夹用中其实非常长的
需要进入非常多的人的旅游
那这就是工业精密码库
另一方面是运动性
它们一般会确设比较良好的密码里的工具的抽象
因为它们面对的功能或者是工程开发者
它要确保它的接口是更简单一动的
而不是说更利于我们使用OPEN ASASA提供了一期
也有工具去进行协议的二次开发
它并不是为了这个所做的
所以它在运动性上其实也没有那么好
那这就是目前已有的学术精密码库和工业精密码库的区别
那也就是我们为什么现在想要去做压扣
那这一部分我们可以看一下压扣的一个结构设计
我们可以简单的这几个模块先简单的看一下
上层是Premative也就是密码常用的源域的模块
然后下面是Base
Base这边的话
大多是一些非常标准化的一些实现
就我们刚才提到的我们还想大多说快啊
332里面的一些东西
然后由TiOS里边这里是会是一些Premative它所用到的一些工具
会放进包括实际商员
然后这里这里我们比较好玩的
是我们在这里去加了一个TiOS的文件家
会在里边去放一些理论码的工具
就比如说我们正常用哪
or或者是run permutation, PRG等等
这里可能需要注意一下
其实我们采用的是大家community
或者说大家在那个讨论中所会接害的一种事情
当然这不并不是非常严谨的事情
如果后续有更玩更贴自现实的软绑口的话
我们有会在这里去做先用的替换
那这里是会有一定的安全性问题
ok
那大概的整个foto的结构是这样
刚才忘了提
实际上在Premative这边
我们会优先Premative是整个压口
在影视器上有余的
我们认为一个主动发力点
那么在Premative这一层我们会
会比较激进的去看一些最新品
会产出的比较有比较大影响力的
或者性能优秀的Premative
可能是近一到两年
我们都会在这一层去实现
因为它会直接去向上层的SPU
或者sql等上层应用
去提供一个非常好的性能
那这里我们
我们为了保证性的
我们每个字模块都有
详细的计算和通信的Bunchmark
然后也会优先支持高安全
高性能的一些协议
那么Base这边
我们基本上是写了一些laptop
去方便我们去使用相应的functionality
对
然后最后这个Mass这边是
我们办完一些图片曲线
以及大准处的一些工庄
那后面我们来简单的介绍一下
压扣的安全性
其实也是很有意思的一个问题
那这里其实就牵扯到
我们对安全的理解
到底什么是安全的
那其实我们在这里
其实可以简单去做一个分寸
实际上我们可以先看一下
左边这个图
如果我们做隐私计算
我们最终想要的是一个安全的隐私计算系统
那么安全的隐私计算系统
就比如说我们想需要一个spo计算引擎
或者我们想做一个sql
就是做一个query
那其实在他们的基础上
那么我们是想要
我们如果想要一个安全的隐私计算系统
实际上我们是想要一个安全的密码协议
比如说我们想要一个安全的ps3
我们想要一个安全的ot
或者我们想要一个
安全的npc框架
就比如说speed类似的协议
那么这里有了安全的密码协议之后
那其实它再向下
它是会分了两部分的
它会分为一部分是理论安全
另一部分是实现安全
理论安全实际上
就刚才我们做提到的ps3
ot1npc框架这些协议
它其实是会发布在顶贿上面
那么它其实就会有一个很好的背书
那么我们会有顶贿论我们的学书报告
做我们实现理论安全的一个背书
但是除了理论安全以外
当然我们马上知道是有实现的安全
那比如说在理论安全上面
我们会认为我们有一个好的as
那我假设我们有一个好的as
但我们的密码协议就是安全
那么什么是一个好的as
那这里就牵扯到我们的实现安全
我们的实现安全一般
像as这种as或者as
TATA安全性是有国际国内标准的
或者一些非常有争议的点
它会有一些社区讨论
讨论出来的大家所都承认的一些规范
那在这里如果我们采用这样的标准的话
我们就可以说它是实现
一定程度上的实现安全
我们在我们讲了这套整个逻辑
说我们我们具体看一个例子
就是我们右边这里
举了一个简单的例子
那现在有一个业务安全需求
我们某一个业务需要一个安全的
计算系统
那ps3协议可以满足这个业务需求
那么这时候我们的业务安全需求
就转化成了下面的密码协议的安全需求
因为我们要做ps3
所以我们需要一个安全的ps3协议
比如说我们有一篇krtps3的论文
然后这篇论文是发在CCS
2016年的CCS上面是一篇典会
所以它的理论安全是有倍数的
那在这里我们可以抽象出来
它其实是有一个理论假设
叫relation robust hash function
那这里我们其实就把上面的这个安全问题
转换到了下面这一条
就是把理论工具的安全需求
我们需要一个安全的CRH实现
那这里其实是有一个知名学者的论文
是efficient and secure multi-party computation
from fixed key block cycles
这篇文章里面它提到了
无功我们是用fixed key AS
实现CRH实际的话
它可以达到某种筹目的安全性
所以我们就采用了这种实现方式
那在这里我们其实可以再往前走一步
那么我们实际上是需要一个安全的
AS实现
那这里其实在一业界已经有很多安全的AS
是像个比如说Open ASA 12
比如说EMP2 piece里面的AS实现
它们都是非常好而且非常高效的
或者我们甚至可以采用一些硬件加速的
算硬件加速的方式去做一个安全的AS
那在这里其实就完成了
我们整个安全链路上的一个避缓
除了我们前面讲的
这个避缓逻辑它具体在压扣里面的实现方式是体现在
我们在每一个压扣模块里面
我们会给它去
我们会去尽量的去给它去加一些注释
去把它尽可能把它的安全逻辑都去写到注释里面
这里我们可以看到就是我们会在这里标上
这是整个IKNPOT的一个描述
然后下面标注了它的安全加速式怎么样
其他的安全假设
这两件假设提到了
提到了它需要一个CRH
这个CRH的实现我们在这里
在我们从下路往下去进行review的时候
我们就可以很好的去追溯每一个模块
它所相关两模块的安全性
究竟是怎么样子的
我们可以直接从我们的Header Commons里面
可以去直接的看到
ok
那这里就是我们到了下一步
就是在有了压扣的安全性之后
我们是如何在压扣上面去进行开发的
那这里其实就会涉及到一些问题
ok
刚才讲完了压扣的安全性
那么我们在这里要讲一下压扣是怎么上
怎么在压扣上去进行开发
然后这里首先是我们先介绍一些工具
简单的在压扣上进行
实际上过去的工具就是压扣
gopro ssl
像上层提供了比较简单的一个
软那么实用的接口
那这里主要其实是为了
通过封装opro ssl
去向上层去提供压扣自己本身
所带类型的一些随机数送成
那这里当然我们是在底层
也用那个也在opro ssl基础上
对随机商员去进行了一些小改变
大家可以感兴趣的话
可以去代码里面具体看一下
后面的话是伪随机数生成器
压扣也提供了一个比较简单的那个
伪随机数生成器的一个方法
我们可以看到
我们可以直接调用这个
prgai rctr去在一个c的和
再提供一个c的和out的情况下
去进行去进行随机数生成
那这个底层实际上
我们是用aes去实现的
这两部分都是比较简单的
那包括压扣实际上
也提供了一些link的使用
比如说link也是网络攻击的使用
比如说压扣
我们可以去简单的通过一些sand接口
或者receive去发送和接收数据
那么这里右边放了一个简单的例子
就是我们如何使用压扣的link
去生成一个去执行一个oT协议
我们可以简单的去看一下这个例子
稍微放大一些
那这里是首先是我们去把用户的信息输进来
就是它究竟是party0还是party1
那么在这里
在这一部分是我们创建整个link的过程
我们可以看到它实际上是把
那个17.0.0.1以及10086当作短口
一边是10086一边是1087
然后他们创建完link context之后
就可以直接去进行一个网络连接成功之后
然后他们把相应的link context
去直接去给到oT
然后就可以去执行得到一个oT的结果
这个用起来还是比较简单的
除了前面的那些部分
其实我们还提供了一些密码的
密码的理论工具
就比如random prormutation等等
这里我们底层实际上是
random prormutation是实际上是用Hash来实现的
在这里有SR26SR32
如果是想要更高兴的一些Hash算法的话
也有Blake2Blake3等等
然后random prormutation是底层是用AS来实现的
这个因为AS它本身就是一个
不属于random的random prormutation
所以我们在实力化random prormutation的时候
这种采用了AS的实现
也是fixkey
好OK
那么前面讲了一个大概的工具
那么在这里我们简单看下
如果我们想要去实现一个
IKNP的oT协议我们应该怎么做
首先我们的IKNP的接口是
是长这个样子的
这里简单介绍一下整个那个
我重新讲一下这个
我更新了
再讲完前面的工具之后
我们在这里就是需要去介绍一下
我们如何使用牙口去写一个IKNP
oT协议
我可以先看一下右边这张图
IKNPoT协议
oT扩展协议
它实际上是将我们BaseoT
所生成的一些比较短
而且数量少的oT
去进行扩展
去进行长度上的扩展
去进行课数上的扩展
就收成很多个oT协议
那么所以在这种基础上
它就可以有这样的一个接口
我们可以看到它把网络输入拿进来
这是BaseoT的输入
然后这是它的输出
它生存的oT的输出
然后后面包括了
它是不是想要oT的一个flag
这里我们不大对这个协议的具体介绍
我们主要看一下
如果要实现这个IKNP协议
那使用牙口我们应该怎么样
那这是整个IKNP协议的流程
实际上在这里
我们假设我们要去实现
这个receiver的话
我们可以看到在整个协议中
我们receiver这端
在收到BaseoT的结果之后
它就需要首先用PRG对C的进行长度扩展
那么使用牙口的话
我们就可以直接生存
将一个随机C的给到PRG
然后用它来进行长度扩展
当然这里说的是给一个随机的C达
那当然在协议里面
我们在用的时候是实际上是
根据BaseoT生存的一些blog
去进行长度扩展就可以了
然后receiver在收到这个结果之后
它进行一系列本机计算
也就是S2
那这个我们就不多说
就比较简单的以后操作
然后将这个操作的结果
直接去发挥给Sanda
然后Sanda在进行系列操作后
整个协议其实就结束了
那么在最后这个阶段
还设计到密码的一个东西
就是它需要把T利用
R1接连去做一个CRH
那么在实际上在那个
我们Random Computation的那个文件里面
我们就添加了一个CRH的实陷
那我们在这里就可以非常简单的直接
针对他们两个blog的一个组合
去进行CRH的计算
那我们可以看到在GT-TEMR里面
实际上receiver这边
实际上是T0 T1的基础上
去进行了一个长度的扩展
可以看到它实用一下
G的AS康复模的去直接
去进行了一个直接去进行了长度的扩展
包括后边的一些计算
以及CRH的计算
大家感兴趣的话
可以去打扩的带往里面
去看一下这个例子
还是挺比较有意思的
那我这次的分享就到此结束了
谢谢大家